is anyone want some skin cancer Jesus
Christ
wait we need two more victims until we
can play oh I needed yeah just ready
I needed to click ready oh you [ __ ]
idiot you forgive you [ __ ] idiots I
have never played the game okay no one's
ever played the game
alright well then one am give me a break
Jesus I've never played a game no will
ever can I'm coming for that booty
I lose Ken what you see me oh sure Fred
hey baby
what the [ __ ] do we do let's get it on
okay I'm just laying out some presents
is that him this oh my god like this
where you saw me you saw me nope no of
course not
she and brand where'd you go I'm hitting
a man I'm [ __ ] ahead
where are you gay for here you get are
you this way where do you go alright
coming on Vegas I'll do Punk you always
run ah yes yeah always run upstairs
that's how you know you're gonna die now
I'm gonna do this ready huh huh oh my
god knows okay that do we have weapons
we have anything that we can do to kill
this alright hey where you going gray
don't look behind me ah
Oh fresh so mundane what the [ __ ] are
you doing for this week's cat you said I
miss [ __ ] CK hit this [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah kick it out out oh my leg run for
your life gonna hide this grass I never
find me in here hey wait where do you go
Oh keep crawling baby oh you got me with
me to not go back to the house baby
wiggle don't wiggle baby you only make
it harder for your Freight oh don't
don't anything [ __ ] I got stay yes Oh
what are you gonna do about it I'm gonna
cut up your nipple my nipple oh yeah
turned into a spy craft fried goodness I
got a smashed face this struggle oh
don't worry about me I'm dead I'm dead
don't worry about me don't worry about
me I said don't worry about me I said
hey put me down
we might be down first oh man you
[ __ ] kidding me
I'm coming for you [ __ ] oh [ __ ] wait
wait wait you're supposed to walk on the
tress what
there's a trap right here oh yeah I got
you ha ha my world place trap got you
once again now you're coming with me
young lag now let's go find your sister
we stop wiggling I'll spank your ass no
not my ass reg run out the door on the
other side of that trash I can tell I'm
not well then we learn father I am my
sweet chap I heard someone mark oh hello
[ __ ] I hear you squealing you will never
find me and let me hear you know what is
in here oh [ __ ] father I am trying to
work we go into the maze mother told me
to study my land as to disobey your
father mother told me to study my
mechanics you can't put me to bed I'm
gonna wiggle free goodnight for Christ's
sake father not this again father
daddy shot a bi we get if we can tweak
it you feel [ __ ] quite why the [ __ ]
we in the woods don't worry about it all
right
yeah I like that a lot and you know I
like that idea now is there a [ __ ]
time Jesus Christ don't look at my ass
right
don't [ __ ] smell it it's been a long
[ __ ] day my ass crack is all sweaty
and [ __ ]
I would love some baby [ __ ] powder to
put it in between if you tell keemstar
about that [ __ ] there yes be careful
Lisa for help
Lisa what the [ __ ] are you dead chicks
dead deaf [ __ ] I married a [ __ ]
weirdo smell you [ __ ] you are my
lawn get our sow the recovering is so
[ __ ] slow let me hear it you know the
pain love you don't touch me on my hands
down [ __ ] touch me man you like it
when I nibble on your ear like this mmm
I do but don't [ __ ] touch me area
yeah you liked it I said you don't
[ __ ] touch me all right
surprise is recombinant no bring it up
we go Lisa I love you honey we're gonna
have babies one day too bad [ __ ] hey
Mel ray man you're going never catch me
where y'all going now I'm gonna find you
and I'm gonna stab you in the face
you're never Felix come save me you're
so [ __ ] slow come he [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] no shut the [ __ ] up right oh
[ __ ] you Oh goddamn fat massage damn is
correct lady
oh yes I know Swedish massage yeah you
like that [ __ ] oh yeah oh [ __ ] Oh what
the [ __ ] was that happen you popped a
vein or some [ __ ] your [ __ ] was that
alright hey he's just getting buck
all right we can hide in these lockers
inside this house okay you take that one
and I'll take the other
go to John over here hopefully he will
never find us
take a man [ __ ] you kids taking a [ __ ]
in my house no I'll find just oh hey
come on now the Plumbing's all backed up
you got a flush twice chuckle baby do a
number on me hey could you pass with no
toilet hey huh hey now listen I don't
know where you are
give me some toilet paper I'm a living
[ __ ] off Terry I'm sure alright get in
in in Saudi cents crisis smells in here
yeah you never made it on the wrong day
are you gonna bring your brain oh god I
got it you're a demon it's gonna get
look I could okay okay okay okay
wiggle wiggle No
Oh dad you just wait there in turn more
help thanks appreciate it
oh [ __ ] just handy after a good [ __ ]
stick emails found with the sorry I
gotta go through it oh not my wife
anyone but my wife oh geez come on now
it's time for you to clean the ship
please separate all over the walls
Lisa [ __ ] my pants come on now let me go
a fate for you as it calls for your
friend
I'll hang you up on here until the
blueberry pancakes are cooked I'm gonna
go get ourselves some blueberry pancakes
by now gonna play you wanna play league
of legends instead know what that what
the [ __ ] are you doing here what the
[ __ ] are you doing
ah